즉 X=Y인 경우인데, 이 경우에는 단순히 Φ가 시스템의 상태를 변환하고 있다고 상상하는 거예요. 실제로 이게
우리가 관심 있는 경우가 매우 많아요. 하지만 이 가능성은 첫 번째 요점과 일치해요. 즉 입력과 출력 시스템이 동시에 두 개의 별도 시스템으로 존재하지 않는다는 의미에서요.
어쨌든 이번 강의에서는 입력과 출력 시스템을 각각 X와 Y라는 다른 문자로 부르는 게
편리할 거예요. 이렇게 하면 헷갈리지 않고 정리할 수 있거든요. 이제 채널이 항상 밀도
행렬을 밀도 행렬로 변환해야 한다는 요건에 대해 좀 더 자세히 알아볼게요. 새로운 시스템 Z를 도입한다고 해봐요.
이 새로운 시스템의 고전적 상태 집합에 gamma라는 이름을 붙여봐요. 이제 채널 Φ의 입력 시스템 X와
함께 새로운 복합 시스템 ZX를 형성한다고 상상해 봐요. 이 복합 시스템이
밀도 행렬 ρ로 표현되는 상태에 있다고 가정해요. 이건 이 쌍의 임의의 양자 상태일 수 있는데, 어떤 상태든
밀도 행렬 ρ를 화면에 표시된 형식으로 표현하는 것이 항상 가능해요. 여기서 A와 B 모두
고전적 상태 집합 gamma를 범위로 하고, 각 ρ_AB는 행과 열이 X의 고전적 상태 집합에 대응하는 행렬이에요.
그 고전적 상태 집합에 이름을 붙일 필요는 없어요. 명확히 말하면, 각 ρ_AB가 반드시 그 자체로
밀도 행렬인 건 아니지만, 전체 행렬 ρ는 반드시 밀도 행렬이에요. 시스템 X에 채널 Φ를 적용하면
X가 Y로 변환되고, 쌍 ZY가 남아요. Φ를 X에만 수행한 후 이 쌍의 상태를 결정하는 방법은
각 행렬 ρ_AB에 선형 사상 Φ를 적용하는 거예요.
다르게 말하면, gamma에 대응하는 행과 열을 갖는 정방 행렬에 대한 항등 사상과 Φ의 텐서곱을 취하는 거예요.
이는 새로운 시스템 Z에는 아무것도 하지 않는 것에 해당해요. 하지만 이건 동등한
설명이고, 이 형태의 사상의 텐서곱에 대한 세부사항을 꼭 다룰 필요는 없어요.
하지만 텐서곱은 벡터와 행렬에서 작동하는 방식과 유사하게 꽤 직관적으로 작동해요. 이걸 시각적으로 생각하는 한 가지 방법은
블록 행렬의 관점에서 보는 거예요. 고전적 상태 집합 gamma가 어떤 양의 정수 M에 대해
0부터 N-1까지의 정수로 구성된다는 단순화 가정을 하면, 이것을 모두 쉽게 적을 수 있어요.
여기 보이는 것처럼요. 이제 Φ가 유효한 채널이 되기 위한 요건을 다시 한번 말씀드리면, 이 과정에서 항상 밀도
행렬을 얻어야 해요. 이건 시스템 Z의 선택과 관계없이, 그리고
밀도 행렬이기만 하면 ρ의 선택과도 관계없이 성립해야 해요. 이게 꽤 엄격한 요건처럼 보일 수도 있고,
확인하기도 매우 어려워 보일 수 있어요. 하지만 강의 끝에서 보게 되겠지만 사실 그렇게 엄격하지도
않고 확인하기 어렵지도 않아요. 특히 이 조건에 대한 좋은 수학적 특성화가 있어요.
이것들은 강의에서 조금 후에 이야기할 다양한 표현들과 연결되어 있어요. 이제 채널의 예시들을 살펴볼게요.
unitary 채널이라고 불리는 전체 채널 범주부터 시작할게요. 간단히 말하면, 이것들은
양자 정보의 단순화된 공식화에서 갖고 있는 것처럼 채널로 본 unitary 연산이에요. 정확히 말하면, U가
시스템 X에 대한 unitary 연산을 나타내는 unitary 행렬이라고 가정해요. 양자 정보의 단순화된 공식화에서는
이 행렬을 주어진 양자 상태 벡터에 곱해서 그 연산이 양자 상태에 미치는 효과를 알아내요.
밀도 행렬에서는 밀도 행렬 왼쪽에 U를, 오른쪽에 U
dagger를 곱해요. 수학적으로는 이 연산을 행렬 U에 의한 켤레로 불러요. 이건
|ψ⟩⟨ψ|가 양자 상태 벡터 ψ로 표현되는 상태를 나타내는 밀도 행렬이라는 것과 일치해요.
그리고 특히 양자 상태 벡터 |ψ⟩에 U를 수행하면 U|ψ⟩를 얻는다는 걸 확인하기 꽤 쉬워요.
그리고 그 밀도 행렬 표현은 그 벡터와 켤레 전치의 곱으로 주어지는데, 이는 U|ψ⟩⟨ψ|U
dagger예요. U|ψ⟩의 켤레 전치를 계산했을 때요. 이 채널이 정의되는 방식은
순수 상태에 대해 의미가 있고, 이것과 선형성을 결합하면 일반 밀도 행렬에 대해서도 의미가 있다는 걸 알 수 있어요.
모든 밀도 행렬이 순수 상태의 볼록 결합으로 표현될 수 있기 때문이에요.
이 정의는 임의의 unitary 연산 U에 대해 항상 유효한 채널을 제공해요. 특히 이런 식으로 unitary 행렬로
켤레를 취하면 행렬의 대각합이 변하지 않아요. 임의의 양의 반정치
행렬을 임의의 행렬로 켤레 취하면 또 다른 양의 반정치 행렬을 얻게 되고,
이건 양의 반정치 행렬의 정의로부터 직접 꽤 쉽게 구할 수 있어요. 그래서 밀도 행렬은 항상 밀도
행렬로 사상돼요. 그리고 이 모든 것은 임의 크기의 항등 행렬과 U를 텐서곱해도 여전히 성립해요.
이는 이 채널을 복합 시스템의 일부에만 적용하는 것과 동등해요. 여기 unitary 채널의 정말 간단한 예시가 있어요.
U 자체를 항등 행렬로 취한다고 가정해요. 이건 항등 채널이라고 불리는 유효한 채널이에요.
아무것도 하지 않는 게 확실히 선형 연산이고, 밀도 행렬에서 시작해서 아무것도 하지 않으면
여전히 밀도 행렬이니까요. 이 채널을 나타내는 기호로 다양한 것들을 써요.
때로는 항등 행렬에 사용하는 것과 완전히 같은 기호를 쓰는데, 이게 약간 혼란스러울 수 있지만 보통은 그렇지 않아요. 여기서는
혼란을 피하기 위해 항등의 약자인 ID 문자를 쓸 거예요. 이 표기법도 꽤 일반적이에요. 매우
지루한 채널처럼 보일 수 있지만, 정보 전송의 맥락에서는 실제로 완벽한 채널이에요.
수신자가 발신자가 보낸 것을 정확히 받는 채널인데, 이런 맥락에서는 일반적으로 가장 원하는 거예요.
채널의 많은 예시를 얻을 수 있는 또 다른 방법은 채널의 볼록 결합을 취하거나, 다시 말해 평균을 내는 거예요.
이것이 가능하다는 사실은 채널의 중요한 측면이에요. 이걸 더 자세히 설명하기 위해 두 채널 Φ_0와 Φ_1부터 시작해요.
그리고 0과 1 사이의 실수 p도 함께 고려해요. 명확히 말하면, 이 두 채널이
같은 입력 시스템 X와 같은 출력 시스템 Y를 갖는다고 가정하는 거예요. 이제 확률 p로 첫 번째 채널 Φ_0를
적용하고, 나머지 확률 1-p로 두 번째 채널 Φ_1을 적용하기로 결정하면 어떻게 되는지 생각해 봐요.
예를 들어, 그 확률로 비트를 무작위로 선택한 다음 이 무작위
비트를 사용해 어느 채널을 적용할지 결정하는 거예요. 이렇게 하면 사이라고 부를 수 있는 새로운 채널을 효과적으로 적용하는 거예요.
이건 시작했던 두 채널의 볼록 결합으로 주어지는데,
화면에 쓰여진 것처럼 표현할 수 있어요. 이런 식으로 선형 사상의 선형 결합을 항상 취할 수 있어요.
그리고 이런 식의 선형